[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time I'm link and I'm
red this week at the round table of dim
lighting we are catching up about our
little Thanksgiving times which ended up
being uh unexpected catastrophic in many
different ways my body but let's start
with the elephant in the room uh which
is your sling you tell my Ned from try
guys oh well I know what you're doing
you're saying uh the the try guys made a
video where they literally had an
elephant in the room to address the Ned
situation which was to literally cover
it much which was clever
um no link has a sling on for those of
you listening a link sling his arm isn't
a sling it's my right arm
oh me so
this was two days ago you know this is a
Tuesday that was a that was a Sunday
morning and man it had been a while
since I've been on my mountain bike dude
I mean like
before Thanksgiving I just I just hadn't
been out there I hadn't been hadn't been
hitting the pedals you know as they say
hitting the hitting the slopes of the
that's not the right sport anyway you
were doing an awesome trick big jump no
I were you by yourself I was by myself I
I was doing my my big run that I like to
do it's like a two hour run and I I was
like it's been a while I don't know if I
can do this and then but I was like you
know you can turn around at any point
because it's an up and back
right
um
and
I'm going up I get to the first saddle
I'm feeling good so I'm like I'm
starting to feel myself
and so I'm going up to the next saddle
which is you know the the main
turnaround point that then you have this
have this long ride all the way down
which is super nice and
you know I'm I'm listening to uh my
music I'm and I'm I get to this one
point is that advised I'm still yeah I
mean I usually listen to a podcast going
up because it's so slow growing up and
then I listen to music airpod Pros
yeah why well so you so you do the thing
where you can hear the environment as
well you don't put on noise canceling
when you ride I do yeah you put on noise
canceling yeah
just so I mean if something if something
pops out that's not a like a consistent
tone you'll still hear it that's what
that's how noise canceling works okay
for the most part
that's why you can well that that didn't
have a factor here if you're trying to
like get ahead of me but I'm going
uphill I mean like the dangerous part
is coming downhill and you know the
irony of this is kind of crazy like
right before Thanksgiving break we
recorded a car biscuit if you don't know
that's when
um we basically do a version of ear
biscuits from a car either my car or
Red's car exclusive to the mythical
Society yeah so every month every month
we do one of those we do and I always
have fun doing those we never know what
we're going to talk about it's like ear
biscuits but even less curated
so you might be into that right the last
the one that's like
probably it's a it's either about to
come out or it just came out we recorded
right before Thanksgiving and we ended
up talking about like
what are the things that we do that are
most likely to injure us and I was like
it has to be mountain biking for me yeah
what's most likely to kill you or what's
most dangerous but yeah but you yeah we
concluded that between the two of us you
were more regularly doing the more
dangerous thing which was mountain
biking the most dangerous and I saw I
mean did is it is that like manifesting
it
I don't I think I believe in
manifestation well did you did it okay
did it cross your mind at any point
before the injury that we had had that
conversation no and I think that's the
problem I don't think it had any impact
coming down the hill is the part where
it's like you gotta be on your your toes
You Gotta Be You got to really be on
guard but going up it's like you can
kind of zone out you can kind of you
know listen to a podcast you're just
cranking away going in in like this
granny gear but then there's this one
place where it does dip down and you get
a little rest and like so it's a slight
Decline and I will and instead of
listening to a podcast this time I was
listening to music on the way up so like
and I was really
happy that I was doing so well okay
um so I just I really cranked it do you
know what song it was
um
it was if it was Freddie Gibbs I don't
know which song and what was a BPM do
you think it was probably
um 98
that's kind of slow it's not too fast
but I'm cranking it okay and
um
I just I guess I just hit this little
divot
and I wasn't I wasn't present I just
wasn't totally present
and
typically when you fall
you can
um kind of catch yourself
a lot of times I kind of know it's
coming like I mean once you mean without
fully falling no falling but like
getting your hands out and like catching
yourself and like I'm wearing gloves I'm
wearing elbow pads I'm wearing knee pads
I'm wearing a helmet okay I'm wearing
all these things because I do fall
um
but this was really unusual I mean my
front tire I think it just took a really
hard boom right turn right when it hit
this
um divot Wham and then it just tossed me
I would say it slammed me more than
tossed me over the right side of the
bike my forward momentum took me over
and it happened so fast
that I did not have time to get my hand
my right hand off The Handlebar
um
to put my hand in front of me and kind
of so that my hand will be the first
thing to hit the ground
so I was diving in my right shoulder was
the first thing was it I dropped it and
so the first thing that hit was the top
of my right shoulder bam into the ground
and then it was like the side of my face
I think like like or the side of my
helmet or something but I really did I
didn't hit my head
it's I didn't I'm pretty I didn't do
that sound you sound like you might not
remember so maybe you did I mean because
that's a big concern but
um
so it was it was like a mouse trap dude
it was just like Wham you know and
um so I'm on my right side
what's the first thought in my yeah
first thought is
have I dislocated my shoulder so I'm
like and I like get off
I get off the ground a little bit and I
raise my right arm and so there was a
little bit of mental relief that like
okay I can raise my right arm I like I
went like this just raised it and I was
like okay my arm is still in socket
because the way that it hit I just felt
like it could have just just taken it
all the way out and my shoulders you
know I have some shoulder issues so it's
kind of
it's it's been historically a little
weak in certain in keeping it in socket
so
I just didn't want to have to do the
Lethal Weapon thing where like you hit
your shoulder against the ground or like
your bike or something to put it back in
socket that was my first thought how far
into the process did you think I'm going
to talk about this on the podcast my
second thought was
I have to get off this Trail because I
know that there's some mountain bikers
that have passed me and some that are
probably just coming down and they can
come down pretty fast and it's they have
to turn around usually you don't want to
pile up I don't want to get hit or I
don't want to send somebody off the
mountain so like then I'm like scooting
to the side of the trail and it and so
on my left side I'm going up the
mountain on my left side it's like a a
decent drop off one that if I sent
somebody careening off of it I would do
more than dislocate their shoulders yeah
and um on the right it's just a slope so
I didn't and some Thicket so I just like
I'm like trying to sit in the thicket
and not panic this is all happening
pretty quickly so that was my second
thought and then my third thought was
I'm not like I've been thinking about
going back to the gym and now I'm gonna
have to shoot the show GMM with like a
sling and like
yeah and because I I think I had assumed
that nothing was dislocated so I'd
broken something
I think I pretty much knew at that point
like it was it was hurting
and it you know that thing where like
like I can move my fingers I raise my
arm but then like as like in minute two
it's like I really my body wouldn't let
me move my arm at all you know so it
just kind of like it knows something
that I don't
uh
and then I'm like
and you know I didn't think about
telling the story yet I was just because
then I kind of went in and almost like
don't freak out don't freak out like I
started like taking don't freak out as
in what do you mean like
I was afraid to look at my shoulder I
was I was afraid I was gonna faint
you're very like you're gonna have a
panic attack up there yeah yeah or just
yeah so like I felt a little faint I I
was like just like just like pouring
sweat I was already pouring sweat but
like
it was that like don't don't pass out
and then one Runner comes down no or
maybe it was a cyclist
I was like dude are you okay
and I was like yeah yeah I'll uh I'll be
fine I just took a fall and I have to
recover so it was just like my instinct
was just like yeah I'm okay keep just
keep going I'll be fine and then
um it was like another couple of minutes
and there was another Runner
um
that came by and she was like are you
okay and
I'm like I took uh yeah I just need
to gather myself so what is your
definition of okay and then because I'm
I'm questioning that at this point I
looked up at her like what did you mean
by that and I was like yeah like I'm not
going I'm not dying I didn't want to
uh inconvenience anybody
have to put you put her you on her back
right
Sherpa me down the mountain
but then I looked up at her and she
wasn't leaving
she knew and I was like ah he is not
okay I'm not okay
I think I've broken my
collarbone
um
I need uh
just to sit here for a little bit oh man
I wish I could talk to this woman and
she was like you know I can just take
you down I can take you down to the
saddle there's more mountain bikers like
we can you know
you can get some help or whatever I was
like okay yeah and then so I sat there
and then she like Stood Beside Me and um
I was
doing some deep breathing and then
occasionally she would ask me
uh questions like
I can't remember but she started talking
to me do you think she was an angel
I think she was an angel yes I think she
was my guardian angel did you get her
number
I'm not like did you get a number I mean
I'm not gonna stay I know I'm a nice
woman I mean do you have to be Christian
to have a guardian angel can you be a
Buddhist and have a guardian angel can
you be anybody yeah I know you can be a
member of the band Alabama but I think
that they're pretty Christian
but you're not going to stay in touch
with this woman who saved you
there's more to this story okay all
right okay all right I'm just
so because a lot of times you can't get
in touch with an angel she's trying
right they don't you call the number and
it just is like they give you a number
but it's a it's a every time that's
happened it's [ __ ] that's what's
happening it's that angel fake yeah
um it took me 15 minutes to be able to
get up
like to be able to stand up right yeah I
was not doing good and she was like do
you have something to eat and I had like
one of these kids bars that like it has
more sugar than a normal protein bar
which is nice because I needed that so I
took a bite and then I was like oh God
I'm gonna vomit
but then I did eat like a third of it
and I'm like drinking my electrolyte
water and like trying to just gather
myself you got a lot you had a lot of
things yeah
you know I I have some stuff I would
have been over there with nothing yeah
yeah
um and
my bike was okay but like the the
freaking Bell on my bike like there's a
bell on the left side of the handlebar
that thing was obliterated and just in
the middle of the the trail like my bike
took a hard Bell well I was like can you
get my bell and then I put it in my put
it in my pocket
and um
let's be a nice Bell
I've learned to not leave the scene of
an accident without looking around
because I've in Falls before
if I'm okay like I'll just get on my
bike and start writing realizing there's
something that's falling off of my bike
and I gotta go back and get it
um so I finally got up and I was like I
I can't get my bike down this mountain I
can't you know she's like I can push
your bike down the mountain that's not a
problem we'll just walk down I was like
thank you so much for doing this I was
just really appreciative and then like
wow we started walking down and
you know it dawned on me it was like if
she didn't stop no only one other Runner
went by and it was a guy who was running
with such intensity going up the
mountain that he passed me running going
up the mountain and I'm on a bike oh
it's like so like this guy ran back down
he was the only other guy that came by
and I I just wouldn't have had the nerve
to ask him to help that's what I told
her I was like I don't know how I would
have gotten down because you're my only
hope
you're my guardian angel
um
and when I said that she disappeared
um
so uh Katie and I just started talking
because
it took yeah wow an hour oh if you walk
down the mountain
with her behind me and me just like
holding my arm in the sling that we made
from she had on two shirts so she took
off her over shirt she was prepared she
was like I wanted I was you know back
before I stood up she was like
I can we can make my shirt into a sling
he was an angel you'll always have an
extra shirt the first thing I thought
was you gonna go down smile without a
shirt
so I like looked up at her listen she
had two shirts it was magic and what I'm
telling you is that you wait what she's
gonna go running in two shirts no an
Angel takes off one shirt and there's
another shirt under there right because
they're operating in a magical way the
layers conceal the wings yeah it's like
okay it's like yeah okay I'm gonna have
to do the short trick with this one
yeah and then she turned her shirt into
a sling yeah which only an angel could
do so far the evidence is strong for
Angel oh gosh yes well every time a bell
rings an angel gets itself
so you're saying when I took the crash
it's like it created the angel It's a
Wonderful yes you manifested an angel
with your freaking Bell I'm glad you
kept it it's a lucky Bell
I kept it
so yeah I mean we we're like best
friends when I finally got home and told
Christy I was like I told her about uh
Katie and then later on I was like yeah
my best friend Julie and she was like I
thought you said her neighbors came you
already forgot your Angels first thing
my best friend Julie
um
I I mean I told her when we got back to
the bottom after that after the hour it
just there's many places you can park
and the place that I parked to start my
ride is not the main place or the second
place it's the third place that requires
a final climb right before you get back
to your car so and it's just on the
street so people don't like to do it but
she also parked up there well yeah yeah
she moved her car while you're all
walking down with her mind
foreign
I mean I don't even think she had a car
because once she put my bike on my I
mean I couldn't do anything yeah it was
a fake call she put my bike on the rack
and then I get in the car and she was
like can you drive are you okay yes yeah
I'm driving and then I drive past her
and she's just walking down the street
like Bill Bixby at the end of The Hulk
she and then I bet when I turned the
corner the wings popped out and she flew
getting into her car yeah right
um I did take a picture with her because
I was like
Katie I I've got a I gotta take a
picture and I know I look happy but I am
not happy like that was my best fake
smile and you're you're zooming in on
her to see if she's
and she's so Angelic they do a good job
of just making themselves look like
normal people I mean that's part of
their deal right I got to know
everything about her husband Ron he's a
he's a bedroom DJ just like me he's more
into house music really yeah works for
Snapchat
we negotiated a new deal for mythical oh
that's great uh with Snapchat she
definitely looks like somebody who could
run run up a mountain she ran up the
freaking mountain and then she walked my
bike down it for an hour and she does
she's not sweaty at all and she was so
gracious I mean she I mean it literally
added basically an hour to to her day so
I got her number yeah she's just doing
her job and I'm getting her um her
mailing address so I can send her some
sort of gift her and Ron a gift yeah
that'll be interesting what that mailing
address ends up being
yeah I don't know if she was 777 Heaven
Street let me see let me see I'll read
it to you right now
okay
nope
nope that's just it's just normal yeah
she could don't read it out loud yeah
okay
here's our address but absolutely no
need to send anything if that's why
you're asking it's not often we get a
genuine chance to help someone out like
that so just happy I could be there to
help
but she did tell me that like
her mom was back home visiting and that
Ron was stuck with the Mother-in-law so
I feel like I got to get Ron a gift yeah
yeah you know so how's it been since
then well because because you ended up
uh you texted everybody in our our close
friend group yeah I didn't know you were
back uh I I had just gotten back uh
which we'll get into uh later that we
ended up not spending Thanksgiving
together uh because of a a conflict
between the two of us no
uh I'll just put everything in in
perspective we made up so I uh I had
just returned and you text the the
friend group that you took a fall and
that you are currently in the emergency
room waiting to see if you broke your
collarbone yeah I tell Shepard because
Shepherd and I are the ones that came
back together uh and Shepard says it
only takes 14 pounds of pressure to uh
to break a collarbone so he probably
broke it
I love it I love it so I was like okay
he broke it we don't even need to be I
sat at the emergency room for over five
hours
got an x-ray
um here it is it is broken the clavicle
is broken like right at right towards
the end of it you know how like my my
shoulders are so bony
you know like the top of my shoulder is
very and now in this in this photo it's
not the Gap but to the right of the Gap
where there's like
the break that's the break so what would
that bone normally look like would it be
is is it bent weird right here yeah like
see the part that's like shaped like an
arrowhead that broke off and typically
that is more like imagine that being
pushed up
and because like look over here like you
know I've got a big bump yeah like my my
clavicle comes out all the way and then
over here it's like taking a hammer and
just bam nailing my bump down and
breaking it off so actually if you look
at let me show you the pic I took a
picture in the mirror this you're saying
right there that part's the break
zoom in I only have one hand that right
there that's the break so to the left of
that break is just a joint no that's the
end of the bone that's been pushed down
imagine this era like this this this
Arrowhead shape thing right here
pushed up where it's in alignment with
everything else
and it would create a bump in my skin at
the top of my shoulder you broke your
Bump yes I I I I broke the bump and
you're not gonna have a bump anymore I
don't think I'm gonna have a good if you
don't get surgery which they told you
you don't need surgery yeah uh the ER
doctor said it's broken I texted the
ortho that I'm recommending you go to
for follow-up I haven't been yet but he
but graciously he responded to his text
because they're friends and said
um no surgery needed which was a big
relief I didn't realize it at the time
but like when I got home you know
Christy would have been Googling and
saying like you're gonna need surgery he
doesn't think I need surgery this is
this is the picture I took this morning
in the mirror
and like what was this some thirst trap
this is some thirst trap stuff here take
that and zoom in I can't zoom in
so look at my look at my right look at
my left shoulder first see that bump
my injured
well first yeah on the right it's Mirror
Image in them hold on yeah I'm looking
at the wrong side so the right side of
the frame so hold on this is actually an
improvement I know it is I feel like
maybe you got to do the other one I know
exactly next year don't do them at the
same time I mean when I go to the ortho
I'm just going to tell them just to like
Hammer my left shoulder down I have like
a normal unbumpy shoulder honestly it's
one of the things that you got a plastic
surgery I'm pretty self-conscious about
is like the bump on my shoulder is so
pronounced and that thing got jammed
into the Mountainside and busted I can't
believe that you don't need surgery I
know nothing about this stuff but it's
just like if you more change the
morphology of your shoulder to this
degree and they're like no surgery
needed I guess it was an unnecessary
bump I and I do that to my elbow elbow
it took yes yeah I'll take him out
Michael okay all right
shaking her as you can notice my
shoulder's not blue yet but look get my
finger like on my other hand I I for a
while I thought I broke my freaking ring
finger on this other hand that thing was
is blue as a
no is your shoulder blue now no this was
taking uh two three hours so weird how
sometimes the brake doesn't actually
lead to Black and blueness I've been
trying to be really positive about it
you're supposed to stay sling for you
know up to six weeks
and it is my dominant arm well um so you
think I know
but I'm trying to be positive about it
it's
um the the the best news is that it
doesn't hurt
like unless I do something what about
sleep with it it doesn't hurt and sleep
on your back no I've trained because of
the shoulder issues that I had years ago
uh and the pillow that my physical
therapist told me that like cylinder
yeah pillow filled with buckwheat seeds
shells
I'm like I sleep like a dead guy on my
back yeah that's that's good to be
prepared for you and yeah because like
I'm basically not in any pain I'm not
taking any pain reliever
and I'm just like not moving at that
have you but what if you bump into
something what if you forget that if I
yeah if I like I took
I'm bummed out that I can't ride my bike
I'm bumped out that I bumped out I am
bumped out I'm bummed out that I can't
go to the gym and work out because I've
been meaning to get back in there
so I'm frustrated but so the only thing
I do is take Jasper for a walk and like
he got he got a little crazy and like
before I know it I'm using my right arm
to like try to restrain it and then I
can feel stuff moving around that
shouldn't be moving in that way that
bone is broken and because it's day
basically day two so like I'm not
and you know taking that picture
it was really hard for me to do like
looking at it or thinking about it is
the thing that makes me uncomfortable I
just start making this noise the inside
of your body in general is not something
you like to think about but have you
ever tried to put deodorant on
your armpit using the hand that's
attached to that armpit
okay I think you made it look pretty
easy I think I could do it that's
because you have a problem I think I
could do it and so like I'm really
frustrated with your wife to do that I
have to sexy she was like do I need to
take a shower with you I was like oh do
I need a sponge bath so I'm I'm in the
process of developing new systems
New Link systems like I can't like one
of the more frustrating things is making
my smoothie and I and I'm and I gave up
eating my smoothie with a spoon your
hand Blended smoothie and then get and
then like scraping it clean and eating
every part of it like there's just
things I have to let go I think this
might be an opportunity to embrace your
actual left-handedness and maybe you
know it's just like when you're a kid
and you break your arm and then you
learn how to write with the other hand
and then you just keep going with it
what are the things that you could do
with your left hand
well I I don't fix my hair on my left
hand this is the best I could do I was
gonna say something
it looks like somebody who uh isn't
familiar with what you typically do with
your hair fix your hair
yeah it's like it's real flat and like
I'll see you but this is a skill oh wow
you made it worse this is a skill I have
to develop I think there are some
there's a lot of positive things that
could come from this
a brace right I broke my collarbone
there's when I was five I don't and I
had to wear I can't put a cast just
weird brace I hated it I don't think
it's because you you at that age you
don't have the discipline like I've got
a lot of discipline to keep that thing
but I mean so my pillow really trained
me to sleep on my back so that that that
was a that was such an important thing
that now I can sleep good I don't have
pain during the day because you also
feel great if you don't roll I I don't I
I don't roll because if if if I broke my
collarbone I might be able to sleep on
the opposite shoulder but then I would
switch without thinking about it oh yeah
Jade is very upset with me because
though she sits there and when I get in
the bed she makes a noise and then I
lift the covers with my right arm and
she gets under my right arm and goes to
sleep and then I put my elbow down over
her that's how we do it every single
night
and now she says her I'm in a sling
most of the time she stays there all
night but like um now she sits there and
she's waiting for me to lift my arm I'm
like
Jade I can't I can't lift my arm
and she's just like mad at me
she feels like I'm shunning her
the other thing that did work out my
favorite is my dependency on my hair
dryer is really it it's it's so
important now because like it's so hard
to dry yourself off after a shower
with one arm really Tim right now a good
hair dryer is the best thing to dry off
with anyway I was already doing that and
now I'm I can still do that and I now I
just leave it out there and when I wash
my hands it's really hard to dry my
hands
like it's hard to drive one hand without
being put the hair dryer on a stand I
put the hair dryer on its side now I
just turn it on and I I dry my hands
like I'm in a McDonald's bathroom
[Music]
you could get a deodorant stand as well
yeah just lean over like like a like a
deer Salt Lick or like a like one of
those things that like cows rub up
against when everybody has a
personalized robot at their house it's
all this will be so much easier Christy
told me last night when we went to bed
she was like
link
if you get up in the middle of the night
don't blow dry your body
I couldn't go back to sleep hold on you
did it in the middle of the night I was
in this like I I was I was like covered
in sweat and sometimes I don't know what
happened but like usually if I wake up
covered in sweat because we have a lot
of covers and we have a I have a dog
sleeping right again I can't believe
your dog stays there because Barbara
gets so hot like it like she gets so hot
two minutes in and she's like peace
so she will yeah I she meaning me I will
get up and change my shirt in the middle
of night it happens occasionally oh how
occasionally
um maybe once or twice a month
if I get if I because my covers feel
good when I get in them and then they
get too hot is there another shirt under
it when you took it off no not an angel
not an angel I couldn't take my shirt
off in the middle of the night put on
another shirt you know I can't do that
with one arm so I just went to the
bathroom and I blow dried my shirt with
me still you're a strange strange man it
was so great but then Christy was up
from Christy
journals because she's gonna write one
hell of a book
foreign
so I'm trying to be positive and um you
know I did it myself and it's worth it
you had a literal Thanksgiving break
huh you know that's that's humorous
thank you glad I didn't break that ball
it didn't break your humorous yeah
uh well I'm glad you're okay link uh and
I'm glad we have an outlet for you to
talk about it did I get did I put you in
the mood to promote something right
quick yeah uh let's talk about Stevie's
podcast best friends back all right is
out for season three with all new
episodes in the premiere episode of the
new season Stevie and Nadine talk about
Mysteries and conspiracies that they
wish they knew the truth about they
cover topics from The Lost Colony to the
Illuminati to T Swift oh so check it out
now on Apple podcast Spotify or wherever
you get your podcast
um would you be willing to
win on my hair no
right now I think you should get your
angel to do that
the uh man so we didn't end up spending
Thanksgiving together
uh even though the GMM episode which of
course everybody loved because all we do
is sit there and talk about how we
didn't want to make an episode so we
just talked about the Thanksgiving plans
that we had
people love the fact that you confronted
me on the ham and like I said uh on the
episode I what did I say on the episode
I'm gonna take it into account yeah
you're gonna take into account okay the
reason we didn't end up spending
Thanksgiving together uh there was a
family thing that I had to go back for
last minute unexpectedly everybody's
fine nothing to worry about but it
changed our Thanksgiving plans so we
were in North Carolina with my family
and we spent Thanksgiving Day with uh my
family and my brother's family and then
some time with my wife's family as well
um so we missed y'all where that ended
up leaving me because you know we were
gonna host the thing at our house and I
was very excited about my multiple
turkeys that we talked about last time I
had all that pickle brine I had all the
peanut oil yeah you did I had two
turkeys ready to go fresh turkeys on
order which apparently you ended up
using
um we picked them up and handed them off
and someone else to prepare but what
that ended up creating wasn't well first
of all literally the day before we left
because again this all happened very
unexpectedly
again nothing for you to worry about but
it did require travel and Jesse was like
well
the first thing she said was can you
just take a suitcase with all your
turkey stuff
and I'm like baby I ain't traveling with
a bunch of pickle juice
and peanut oil I am not that guy
you know what I'm saying it requires
like special I'm not going to be that
guy
and she said well how about we order
some things and you can get them shipped
to your brother's house and long story
short what ended up happening was I was
going to fry a turkey
so we needed to get a turkey a fresh
turkey because I still wanted to brine
it not pickle brine it but just brine it
and you know the whole you know the
whole deal just just fried turkey yeah
fry a couple of turkeys actually
um
and so I did that it was great I it was
the best turkey I've ever made I feel
like I don't know what it was something
about the elevation or just being back
on my home turf in North Carolina but
I ended up
doing a perfect turkey and I've been you
know zeroing in on the perfect turkey
over the past few years but never quite
Landing it but you didn't do you didn't
do the pickle brine I didn't do the
pickle brine uh but you don't need it uh
no no no so my idea and you know we
discussed this on the the thread and I
think Christy is into the idea uh is
just we should do like a secondary
Thanksgiving dinner you know yeah before
but it could be like a Christmas dinner
almost you know before we go back home
again
but yeah I just hit the temperature just
right it was the breast was so tender
and juicy every it was crazy I don't
know what happened man I nailed it
um
but
while we were you know we actually sent
the our my kids and my nephews off to
the grocery store to get things last
minute and while they were in the
grocery store we were FaceTiming and
I was like you know while you're there
get a ham
it was like you know I was I've been
thinking about Lynx ham and I love I've
already stated that I really love ham it
I think that it's you know probably the
superior meat and you know it'll be
leftovers for everybody
so I'm going to do two a turkey a turkey
breast and a ham what do you mean you're
going to do a ham well let me I learned
a lot
um I learned that
the ham doesn't require much at all
and so it was a little bit it was a
little ironic because I got this ham we
got a spiral cut ham just from Harris
Teeter yeah
and uh so not a honey baked ham because
we were last minute situation
and I just like pulled this thing out it
says fully cooked it has some
instruction it has some some uh brown
sugar glaze that comes with it and the
instructions are place in oven at 350
degrees for 10 to 14 minutes
and then pull it out and put the glaze
on it five to ten minutes later it'll be
sticky ready to go
and I gotta say uh we did that and it
was wonderful yeah there's also the
easiest dish
of all the dishes that anyone prepared
um
I I'm not trying to rub it in but I just
made me think it's like all these years
you've been you've already been through
this you've been doing what we described
but then in my experience no I would do
it instead of putting an oven I would
put it on the grill so it would have a
smoky taste which is nice yeah
uh but yeah I would burn it
so anyway the ham was great the ham was
a hit
um
but I but I had to get a ham just so you
could do this to me no no no no I got a
ham because I was like why not like I
was gonna have ham I was looking for I
still here's the thing
I still eat your ham and I'm not too
sensitive to dry I mean I like white
meat chicken I like a breast I'm not too
sensitive to dryness on meat so it
wasn't like I don't want to have this
conversation I'm always like I still
like it it just could be moisture listen
but what the first time we had the
conversation I was out I was receptive
foreign
what happened uh I ordered a honey baked
ham and it was the best decision that
I've ever made that honey baked ham not
a sponsor so freaking awesome so good
yeah and then
you just take it out of the fridge yeah
and then 30 minutes later you eat it you
just let it you let it come you don't
glaze it you don't do nothing it's all
because they've glazed it already gosh
it's so
it's it's it's
perfect
it's perfect why Why Try to approach
that like even the thing that you made
that I bet was great or good whatever it
was even if it was fabulous
it wasn't better than a honey baked ham
no it wasn't now I bet you they're
expensive
I don't remember the price but like
um it wasn't any more expensive than
those like really expensive turkeys that
you bought that we had to pick up oh
look it's a fresh turkey a fresh organic
turkey is very expensive okay 85 turkey
but the uh the the my ham my spiral cut
ham that I got the only reason you put
it in the oven is to get it to room
temperature okay so so well the honey I
mean it's just so it was still so it was
and I had to you know I I ordered it
like after we had the conversation I
went ahead and reserved one because like
people will line up around the block for
those things what was the line like
I didn't pick it up myself oh okay all
right who sent your angel
oh yeah I did I didn't even pick it up I
didn't okay I didn't order it I didn't
pick it up okay did you I didn't did you
take it out of the fridge I didn't
I did what part did you do I Googled how
long to take it out of there because is
this still links ham is it like if you
take a boat and you slowly replace it
every single part over a period of time
this is still the same boat none of us I
don't believe that this is your time
anymore which is uh it was my money an
interesting situation I bought it okay
it was my money all right and it wasn't
even my decision it was pretty much your
decision and then you weren't even this
is now my hand no it's not your hand
it's not how much ham is it is it our
ham I mean
uh it can be your hand
I'm still the hand you're still the hand
man I'm gonna bring the I'm going to
bring I don't want to take that title
everything
like and you know what have you met link
he brings a ham
it's it and it's unapologetically Honey
Baked yeah did it did you have The
Branding on it now my shoulder's hurting
like something about well something
about this it's like moving thinking
about my posture you've pushed my
posture into a defensive position no
well you have very you have very good
posture you stand up very straight and I
think maybe you stand up straighter
while on camera than you do a normal
life and so maybe maybe
I'm actually trying to keep my posture
really good I'm going to take a visit to
my physical therapist to ask I want it
to I want it to heal in the right place
I'm nervous about that so I'm going to
the ortho and I'm going to my physical
therapist for a consult even before I
start physical therapy because I want to
do everything in order to
heal it in the right place which kind of
I put my shoulders back
it seems like you're in pain
I feel like I might think all of a
sudden okay well I think you should calm
down
focus on the ham
the ham was so good and uh well here's
the other thing you're doing sweating
too does anybody have a blow oh here's
what you're doing you're grabbing the
microphone stand with your right hand
you have you have now you're no longer
using the sling so as we talked about
the ham you grasp the microphone so so
you need to bring it back down you need
to relax the arm yeah yeah and just put
it in a neutral position
and uh just make sure we we're all
rolling if he faints yeah I'm feeling
we're still good because I'm
apprecially okay so I'm glad the hand
was a success uh how how was it turkey
I know it's not a competition the turkey
was amazing right
I heard that it was good but no one was
so good but no one was did you did you
even eat any of it I did
just so I could tell you how amazing it
was okay I gotta tell you Jeb took your
turkey and he put it in some sort of
like I heard it used an air fryer some
sort of like turkey sized air fryer and
let me tell you man
I've never experienced anything like it
it was probably the best turkey I've
ever had are you are you bullshitting me
right now
oh it was a it was really amazing what
did he do to it you know I don't even
like turkey
but I I changed my mind
after all these years changed my mind
well you don't even eat my turkey I
taste it
but I'm always open to it changing my
mind but what did he do tell me what he
did
I just told you put it in if you put in
an air fryer
because I heard that he was doing some
uh
the way Jenny described it was some
trial runs because oh yeah you had built
it up some expectations now he was
taking over okay all right we'll see
about next year Jim
yeah I think at one point he asked wait
am I maybe am I off brand Rhett maybe
we'll have a turkey Tango I think I
think you guys need a Face-Off okay all
right uh his turkey was um
as good as any turkey but I really don't
I you know I don't care enough about
turkey to have it but you but you ate
the dark meat I assume no I just I
grabbed some of it just so I could I
could uh give you [ __ ] about it okay no
it was it was good but I'm just I'm a
ham man
yeah
so appreciate it it didn't really
it didn't really sway me but it was good
it was good it was fine
um
the other thing
the other thing from you uh okay the
other the other Thanksgiving thing okay
yeah
um
I did you you know you're a soccer guy
you know at least I mean you played
soccer and you in fact uh in high school
just recently you played soccer on the
show
people seem to be impressed with your
kicking oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
um so do you are you a World Cup guy no
sir
no sir so there's no I'm a ham man and
more I like music
okay well you don't have to pick one I
mean I'm in a music and ham so I don't
like sports and turkey so there's no
okay so no world cupping hat has
happened no I mean I I listen to the I
listen to the news headlines and if
something is headline worthy I'll I'll
take note
um well I uh I had the privilege
uh what so okay I'm it's Friday after
Thanksgiving and this is the annual
state Carolina football game which
um
NC State and University of North
Carolina Chapel Hill Rivals my wife went
to Carolina I went to State uh but there
was an opportunity to go to the game but
I was like I don't really want to go to
Chapel Hill and watch State get beat
that was kind of what I was thinking
because you know State's playing with
their fourth string quarterback and like
we've been through three quarterbacks to
get to the guy the fourth string oh wow
the scout team quarterback yeah don't go
and I don't want to be in Chapel Hill
and people know I'm a State fan if I get
recognized then I'm sitting there
watching my team lose in public you know
it's not my thing
kind of like getting recognized at the
ER
I had a couple pictures oh good yeah uh
and the but lock and then my two nephews
went to the game
and I was like well I'm gonna I'm gonna
watch the game but I'm going over to my
to Jesse's sister
sister's house and uh they're very
excited about the World Cup like this I
mean I didn't really expect it I mean
I'm like I'm like if a game's on I'll
watch it if the U.S is playing I'll
watch it but I'm not going to sign I'm
not going to make I'm not going to make
an appointment right it's just not my
thing I call it soccer you know what I'm
saying I don't call it football
I call it soccer and
but okay us is okay they're gonna play
um England this is a big deal our team's
really young and England's really good
and like so okay we'll watch it and but
I'm thinking the whole time like but
yeah but that state Carolina game is
like coming on before this game's over
and again I know this is an interest I
had
there's this soccer versus American
football conversation which the only
people on the face of the planet who
think that American football is better
than soccer are Americans right yeah
right and there's a lot of Americans who
agree with the rest of the world it's
like the metric system
okay
um and I think that's a good analogy
because I'm not saying it makes any
sense I mean clearly the metric system
is a superior system than the Kings
system of pounds and inches uh but I
just got to tell you I had the distinct
experience of watching
the game the soccer game and then the
football game back to back and for me
it's like all this excitement around the
US and England and then we're supposed
to walk away from this
satisfied that the score was zero to
zero wow
and we're but we're happy about this and
it's awesome yeah I don't and then I and
then we change the channel We Begin
watching State and Carolina play
football
and it goes into double overtime
and it was crazy it was just crazy back
and forth Jenna was watching it oh yeah
and yeah it was like
it you know and I'm like what this dude
this dude Finley whose Brother played a
state a few years ago who's not supposed
to be great he's throwing these crazy
passes and and then it gets down to the
end and they they score a touchdown but
then it gets ruled in complete and but
then it was zero seconds I'm I'm
watching the game with my father-in-law
who you know went to UNC undergrad and
UNC Dental School yeah huge Carolina fan
and so and we're the only two who really
care in the house so we're the only ones
who were there the whole time yelling
each other he's hitting me oh you know
like what I mean like they score he like
punches me in the shoulder that kind of
thing we have that kind of relationship
don't uh don't do that I'm not gonna do
it to you and
it just none of this was just so you
know none of this was happening during
USA versus England there was no punching
in the shoulder there was no standing I
just I'm just saying I've tried I
enjoyed it you know I think we're
playing and today I think we're playing
Iran when we're recording this and
probably right now I mean I'm interested
to know what happens I would watch it if
I didn't have to work
but
goes into double over time State wins
I'm freaking it's just amazing and it's
awesome to be able to watch it with a
Carolina fan and watch them sort of
shrivel and then we turn the channel to
the Carolina basketball game number one
Carolina is get like literally gets beat
by Iowa State like we turn it over in
like 30 seconds left on the clock and
they lose and it was just like this and
again this is immature this is not
something that I want to promote I'm
just letting you know that it was you've
just chosen to talk about it it was
insanely satisfying to watch Carolina
get beat and State beat them in football
and then went on that night to win in
basketball
uh I'm not saying that we'll beat him on
basketball later but
I just had a like a one-to-one
experience of soccer versus American
football and my suspicions were
confirmed that I'm significantly more
entertained by American football I
I thought maybe I would get a different
perspective from a soccer guy but I
guess you're just a ham guy
and um yeah I was looking I was looking
forward to you defending
soccer well you know the it's a it's
quite an aerobic workout
they're constantly running
that hey I was thinking that I was
thinking these dudes are running around
for 45 minutes oh yeah and like the
football players are like getting a lot
of breaks it's like oh you you I I just
played defense a lot of knees I'm just
playing defense I mean what if you just
play offense and we take a lot of breaks
right you stand around and there's time
out the team watches how do you run
around for 45 it's incredibly impressive
it's incredibly impressive but it's just
the goal something the goal needs to be
bigger something needs to change just
something needs to change a little bit
like the goal either let's get rid of
the keeper or let's make the goal bigger
we need what we need one of those
options to happen trap doors man America
will be all over it trap doors what if
we what if we invented a new thing
called American soccer we don't have to
get the rest of the World to Change I
don't know why would it be called
American soccer uh well just okay it
might be a little redundant American
football but
I think we just call it soccer and then
parentheses American just to remind you
because what I'm saying is that the
rules are going to be different and
we're going to have a giant goal in fact
one whole side of the field is just a
goal like when you get down to that side
and it's just a goal it's just a net
it's like a gutter if you can get the
ball in the gutter it's a point I think
you're describing an end zone
exactly I just created an end zone this
is how American football got created
because they were like how do we make
this easier what if you just carry it
across this line what if you could touch
it with your hands and run it across
this line
we don't have to do that but let's just
make the end a gutter and if you could
get into the gutter it's a goal games
will be like 48 to 45.
everybody will be watching
hey man I I don't want to join you on
this hill because
I don't know you shot shots are gonna be
fine I know it's not a popular opinion I
appreciate it I think that I understand
that soccer is like every man's game
it's like it's much easily more easily
accessible all you need is a ball and
you can just start playing it in your
neighborhood yeah I'm an Outdoorsman
your hair is looking a little like you
touch it with your left hand I know I
know it's like
me and the boys from like the Saturday
before Thanksgiving to Wednesday so
Saturday Sunday Monday Tuesday uh four
days five nights we went on a van
camping trip you know I rented the
Sprinter van
the one that me and Chris went on and we
actually uh I took the boys on on pretty
much the same trip that I took that
Chrissy and I went on uh during the
pandemic when we went to you know when
we went to Zion and Bryce Canyon and
um then we had that weird encounter with
the serial killer with the guy yeah with
the serial killer who wanted to show her
his um his photos so she could vote on
them
uh nothing that scary happened but when
you go in uh November which was uh
weeks later than when Christy and I went
I think maybe we went in September a
little nippy out there huh
um but I wanted to take the boys back to
the Narrows which I mean the the famous
hikes at Zion are um you got Angels
Landing this is so beautiful I highly
recommend it
um Angel's Landing is like you got this
um
what's it called it's not a cavern
Canyon good gosh oh I didn't hit her
ahead
um
and then in the middle of it there's
like this rock formation that you can
kind of hike out to that's like you got
to use these special cables and stuff
and you got to get a permit to go out
there I really want to do that but like
there's no way that I'm doing that with
the boys and like I didn't think I was I
was ready for it anyway
um so we did the hike that Christy and I
did which is an absolutely amazing hike
the uh the Virgin River has carved this
Canyon and then at the at the far end
of
the park
you can hike a trail that then you get
in the water and then you're hiking in
the river
which when Chrissy and I did it it was
like
ankle to it some places need depth and
it was cold at the time so I did my
research and I was like I really want
the boys to experience this Christy
really built it up for Lando and like he
was excited about it about going one day
so I was like boys we can do this and
it's going to be more of an adventure
because yes the water is could be like
27 degrees
that's pretty dang cold that's pretty
dang cold
um and now I'm questioning is that even
right well that would be definitely in
the 30s
I mean 32 is freezing but if it's moving
it's moving
um yeah so there's like there's ice and
snow around it's not snowing there or it
wasn't predicted to but we had to rent
special equipment
like a
special pant like dry suit pants
so that you you wear a couple of layers
underneath it and then you pull these
like it's kind of like waders but
they're really tight at the ankles so
they don't let water in so it's a it's
like a dry suit bottom and then like
special hiking boots and neoprene socks
so that your feet do get wet like
potentially completely wet but then just
like a wetsuit the water inside of the
neoprene socks is heated by your
circulation and your feet stay warm
do you rent these shoes and everything
yeah yeah yeah yeah you rent all of that
a number of people were doing it if you
go in November you can pretty much have
the place to yourself is what I read
because it's cold because it's so cold
people don't want to do that like a lot
of times you go to Zion and
from the pictures I've seen it's like
there's just a lot of people in that
Canyon and does it close
um like is it almost about to close
I don't think it gets it doesn't get
snow like that so I don't think it um
I don't think it does
but don't quote me on that
but um
we did that it was quite an adventure
because it was Thanksgiving week there
were almost many people as when Christy
and I went during covet so it was like
it was still very manageable but it was
it was quite an adventure I mean it was
it was five hours a five hour hike
because we went basically all the way
into where they recommend turning around
and then coming back out
uh you're in the same van
yeah and I was impressed with Lando you
know with his height having to trudge
through that water
he's encountered a lot more resistance
than Lincoln and I are because you know
Lincoln's freaking taller than me now oh
yeah six freaking one crazy and you
haven't may end up being a walking stick
the tallest me all of our kids I mean
Shepherds how tall is Locke
five eleven oh really yeah and uh yeah
that's crazy I mean in law and Shepard
is like five ten and a half but he's
only 14 so he's probably I don't know it
could be weird Shepard is gonna start
some rumors you were six four when you
were Shepherd's age oh yeah six four and
eighth grade
that's crazy man thankfully my kids did
not get uh all of that yeah there was a
there was a balancing Factor
called Jesse
now so but Lando did great and like you
know we get we got some good pictures
had a good time you know it was it was
uh it got pretty cold at night
budget but you got but there's heat in
the van so it's like it's definitely
glamping and um so yeah we had a we had
a good time no
no weird run-ins with strange people
um
and then
I'm also so tired
I feel like I feel like
you might be one of those people that
keeps their brain a part of their brain
and their shoulder no I think it could
have been without a little bit like last
night at eight o'clock I was like
I think I'm going to turn in and
Chrissy's like hold on we need to watch
the White Lotus oh it's only eight
o'clock good
I was like I think that my body is my my
body is rebuilding the shoulder yeah
there's a lot of yeah you know Making
Connections that you don't typically
make yeah it's not you can't make
connections like my my my bone is sewing
itself back together
but
uh we had a really good time and it was
it was special I I don't think that me
and the boys have ever done a camper
trip just the three of us that we could
recall and I remember I'm jealous man
because I you know I was gonna do uh a
shorter trip
with your boys with my boys but with our
plans changing so Lando learned how to
whistle oh you know we're sitting by the
campfire the first night and he's like
you really like to learn how to whistle
I was like son this is the perfect place
and the perfect time we got nothing to
do except sit here by a fire and learn
to whistle it's a whistle lesson
involved
you whistling well just just do this you
know just just do this keep trying now
you can't whistle now change it
okay you can whistle but you're not good
at it I can whistle and I got two no's
oh I've got four notes now can you do it
without moving your eyebrows
[Music]
whistle a tune yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna
hum a tune no no no no no no not a
random tune no that was sitting on
another way match my tune
[Music]
nope it wasn't it wasn't I've got like
there's like three tones that I can do
yeah I mean listen but you just accept
from The Little Mermaid you just Accuse
Me by not being able to whistle and I
Whistle immediately that's gotta say but
I mean I'm not good at it you're bad at
it oh okay well bad at it would be not
being able to do it
no you're bad at Whistling if you can't
whistle you and you can't whistle
okay I just think it's good for you to
say that you're bad at something well
I'll just say you're bad at Whistling I
just think I could be a lot worse why
can't you just say if there's a spectrum
of wisdom I'm not good at Whistling I'm
not good at Whistling but a bad Whistler
is too strong of a word if there's a
spectrum of whistle give me your best
whistle I'm on the lower I'm I am in the
50th percentile or lower easy I would
say that I'm in the 30th percentile well
then you're a bad Whistler well no I
wasn't what is the percentile of a good
of a bad Whistler 15 or down
whistle
that's that's bad dude but I'm better
than I'm fearing I'm better bearing wind
more than whistling if you take
everybody who can whistle
I'm better than 30 of them no you're not
okay we're gonna have to we're gonna
have to figure out a way to do it like
when when you hear that kind of stuff
that's that that's not whistling no but
that that's that's 70 of your whistle oh
no it's not
[Music]
yeah
just be bad at it dude okay if the if if
the lower 50 is the bad half I'm on the
bad half but there are worse whistlers
than me without a doubt name something
you're bad at
and say it this way I am bad at blank I
am bad at being short
you see
you see this
do you hear this
I am bad at not having a beard
I will I will Lando is a bad Whistler
but you know he's just learning he's
just learning he's just learning did he
get better than me during his lesson
yeah oh come on well he's got a Neil
mouth I mean it's a lot of it's the
tongue when you really try to teach
somebody to whistle you really disappear
here's the thing here's the thing
now in the golf world there's something
called a handicap right and I think yeah
change the subject to something you know
no in the whistle world you have a mouth
handicap if you have my mouth you're
starting off so far behind with whistle
ability that I think for everyone who
has a mouth like me I am in the 90th
percentile of people with a mouth like
it's relative dude if you've got a
McLaughlin mouth which is really a cow
in mouth if you've got a cow in mouth
I'm in the 90th percentile of probably
if your last name is Cowan
I'm probably a better Whistler than you
what about that can you do that oh I
can't do that no
okay I don't even know what I I don't
even know how to begin what you're doing
there
don't even know
now I'm not a great Whistler
okay I'm a I'm a good whistle okay what
percentile do you think you are um I'd
say six six six sixty eight percent
okay I'm sure you're more than twice as
good that should be good enough
well it's not about me being that much
better than you it's about you being
completely defeated at something
and not even in a competitive way this
is not about me this is just about you
isolated being bad at something and
being okay with it if you said if you
told me to whistle and I went
they think they would be like okay
that's not a bad Whistler that is that's
someone who can't win yes but I made
whistle noises you you
can with wait and that did surprise me
okay so okay so maybe the the I didn't
know you were even a whistle maybe the
whistle that you thought I was is a bad
Whistler but I I and I accept I'm a bad
Whistler but they're whistlers who are
much worse than me I already said that
I'm on the bad half if you're in the
30th percentile of a whistle you're a
bad Whistler but you made what you said
no I said that at least five minutes ago
run the tape back I said I am on the bad
side of whistling
I'm definitely not a good whistler
I know that
I'm just stating facts I'm not trying to
I'm not trying to to change anything I'm
not the one who's distorting the reality
here
I want you to admit to yourself
what you are okay here's some other
things I'm bad at I'm bad at Birmingham
I I I I I I learned that I learned that
this Thanksgiving yeah that was a quick
lesson
I'm bad at liking soccer do you have a
recommendation
oh God I just came up with three things
I'm bad at
being short liking soccer and Birmingham
and you thought it was saying you're bad
at things and and you thought it was
gonna be difficult for me well I thought
we might talk more about this but I'll
just make it my wreck White Lotus
um
easily the best show on television
according to me it's not as good as
season one uh I mean that's first of all
I love it and I re I really enjoy
watching it
but that's my take it's not well
nothing's ever as good as season one I
bet season three will be amazing
season two is amazing it's kind of it's
kind of narrow in scope and so then if
you're like it's such what what would
you say it's an exploration of
sex I think it's an explanation of
fidelity why Fidelity but also
like trust yeah but also
um
but sex separated from relationship too
for some like there's different there's
a lot of different kids yes
okay yeah definitely Fidelity but also
like
your view of sex that then leads to a
definition of fidelity or not
like separating like there was a
conversation about the difference
between being in love and companionship
and
um an affair like I I'm I'm still trying
to figure out exactly what it's about
but I think it's a little bit more than
Fidelity in my opinion but it's all
within that world that like
I don't know it feels a little narrower
than season one so it's like every
single character is they're all
exploding the same thing was that I
didn't think that was the case with
season one
uh I know I think there was the there
was definitely a a theme you know
there's like themes that run through
each season I I thought there were more
with season one so it's like they were
I'm just I'm not comparing see if you if
I'm recommending this I'm recommending
that you start with season one you can
start and you can also start with season
two but definitely I just think that
the way that the show explores a subject
in the in the characters and the way
that I mean I don't know it's pretty
great as I get older I just find myself
having a more difficult time like
watching you know fantasy stuff like
Game of Thrones or Lord of the Rings
like which I was more into especially
Lord of the Rings like
I I don't and I'm not saying one is
better than the other but I'm just
saying for me something about me getting
older I just find myself I'm looking
forward to the next White Lotus episode
like I'm gonna I'm going to be
completely engaged the entire time it's
very refreshing in that way
I don't know I I do feel like I love
Mike white man I want to meet that dude
in terms of Comedy
yeah for it to be a comedy first
andromedy I guess and be so character
driven and so location based like it's
just fun because you're on vacation when
you watch it you know the main thing
that's so dude you're in Italy do you
watch it uh and then watch the thing at
the end do you let the credits play and
then watch the little thing that HBO
does where they like the actors talk
about them so they'll take two actors
from the show and then that usually two
actors that are connected on the show so
like the the Granddad and this and the
dad together or whatever or oh okay the
two couples are like Austrian
and the thing that always bothers me I
don't know why this bothers me but it
makes me feel duped and it happens so
often is when you find out that a
character that you're like that dude is
killing it in his character is just a
British guy playing an American dude
both husbands both husbands are British
what both of them what
and it's just like I don't think an
American could do that I mean I know
that Emma Stone was great or something
people think that I don't know what the
the English people think about this if
they think that Americans who play well
the thing is good at it but how are they
how are they so good at like specific
especially they're small like they gotta
play by our rule the douchebag they
gotta figure it out the douchebag
husband
England how do they little come in to
this and then find the niche person that
that guy is and so
specifically nail it isn't Daniel Daniel
Craig is I know now I'm talking about
the Glass Onion but he's British right
he's changing yeah
wait and he's like at this like
crazy southern accent there's got to be
some social science theory about why
English people are so well equipped to
play different types of Americans where
Americans and obviously American culture
of three entertainment has been exported
in a much more significant way I think
so that like
we don't really know like how you talk
if you're I mean okay if you're from
Liverpool you talk like the Animaniacs
and if you're from you know Manchester
you talk a certain way if you're from
London East London like you kind of know
a little bit but like I feel like more
of people across the pond know that like
oh somebody from the south talks like
this somebody from New York talks like
this somebody from California like I
think maybe they're just more familiar
with it and so they kind of grow up with
it in a more significant way I don't
know I'm trying to like what because the
thing I was telling Christy was that guy
like the um you know the total dick the
the husband the douche husband yeah the
douchebags I'm talking about he's
British yeah yeah what I was trying to
figure out was like he's so good at
playing that character is that who he
isn't really is that like how close
what's he like in real life because he
looks like his look is so perfectly cast
but now that I was like this is so
obvious that's the case
now what do you think about his wife
do you think she's so good at everyone's
oh yeah they're curious so you don't
know you're trying oh no
I know where everybody's from oh you
want to know where she's from like the
strawberry blonde yeah you think she's
British
um no
she's not she's just from Massachusetts
and she when she talks she just kind of
just talks like it's not as funny as
season one I'm sorry did I say that it
was better than season one no no I said
you're not gonna like it
going I'm sorry to Mike White don't be
sorry it's still why why isn't it it's
still
it's great it's still wonderful it's
wonderful it's still wonderful but
season one was one of my favorite
seasons of the reason it's not as funny
as season one is because there's no one
as funny as the dad in season one the
dad and the teenage son together that
was great so there's a dad and a younger
son this this season but they're it's
not they're not funny it's like it's
it's more intense I I like it yeah and I
think I like it just as much but it
isn't as funny I just don't and you know
the exploration of infidelity is is a
hurdle for me it's just not something
that I like I like to be entertained by
so it's like when you in season one the
the thing when they were talking about
white privilege and all those things
it's like I was I was more engaged it
was those things weren't I mean they
might have been prickly and I'm and I
might have been like oh this is like
some of this hits home so it wasn't I
thought it wasn't it's not as related it
was uncomfortable yeah but this is this
make you know it makes me a little
uncomfortable in a different way so it's
like I have to overcome that I think
that's the big thing well that's what
Jesse said the other night we were
watching it this is becoming a long
wreck we need to wrap it up but she said
I feel so he's so good at making me feel
uncomfortable and and we but and we both
were like yeah and that's why this is so
great like yeah it's like I feel so
uncomfortable with the tension in this
couple right now in a way that it's so
palpable I don't know again if you're
not
I wonder how much being middle-aged
plays into really enjoying this so like
I would couch the wreck but
not my wreck I'm not going to catch it
I'm going to say sit your ass on the
couch and watch White Lotus
all right
um let us know what you think about all
of this you know the lines are open 1888
earpod one hashtag your biscuits I
should have worn a hat
figure it out man baby steps
hi writtenly I have a bones pick with
Rhett about a comment that he made um
last uh well the most recent episode of
ear biscuits Brett said that the
difference between a patio and a porch
is that a porch is covered I think the
difference between a patio and a porch
is a porch is built or elevated off the
ground and may or may not have a
covering over the top of it well a patio
is a concrete pad that you step out or
down onto out of your house that's it
thanks guys hey Rhett and Link Ross
McIntyre from Cornelia Georgia first
time listener long time caller I was
calling in response to the uh blue paint
on the ceilings of Southern home as I
understand it it has nothing to do with
bugs or anything like that it's actually
called haint blue and it's two ward off
evil spirit as weird as that may sound
thanks keep doing what you're doing hey
there guys long long time listener to
the podcast in your show you guys have
been there
when nobody else was just wanted to say
Spotify rap came out today and rat
your song Believe Me James and the shame
was my number two most listened to song
for the entire year of 2022 coming in
second only to the great Jason Isbell so
I just thought I would let you know so
you guys keep being you and uh thanks
for everything you've done for all of us
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
foreign
[Music]